Okay, and that's Stratton's Taxonomy.
Data layout transformation, transforming scatter patterns to gather patterns.
Tiling, so that we can share input upon multiple threads.
Privatization, so that we can avoid sharing output, as long as possible.
Binning and spatial data structures, so that we can reduce the amount of input
that's necessary to look at for given output.
Compaction, so that we can avoid processing inactive
inputs and process more efficiently on a sparse set of inputs.
And regularization, where we can extract regular parallelism from irregular parallelism,
often in the face of strategies like binning and spatial data structures or the scatter to gather transformation.
Now you've encountered most of these ideas already in the class.
But I do hope this overview helps you think consciously
about the strategies you can employ to optimize parallel programs.
I definitely recommend that you read the original papers if you're interested in learning more.
They give examples from much different bench marks
and describe case studies for some of these techniques.
I find them useful to help me be principled in my thinking about Parallel Optimization.
I'll include, again, links to those papers in the instructor's notes and on the wiki and so forth.